what is up everybody it's animak here
for anime uproar and today i will be
trying to figure out what is going on in
black clover osta has been bruised and
battered chapter after chapter and now
he appears to be literally on the brink
of death lucifero is an absolute monster
and it doesn't look like anyone can stop
him even though he's only using like
half of his full power is this the end
of our boy asta and the clover kingdom
magic knight captains is tabitha about
to pull off the ultimate troll let's
talk about it if you guys enjoy our
black lower videos and you want to see
more in the future you know what to do
just leave a quick like and comment it
only takes a second but it really helps
with the youtube algorithm and of course
if you're new here or you watch our
videos regularly but you just haven't
taken the time to subscribe yet it would
be helping me a lot if you took the time
to subscribe and hit that notification
bell to turn on all notifications big
thank you to all of our anime upper
patrons who make it possible for us to
make a bunch of different videos every
single week i'll talk more about patreon
at the end of the video but first please
be advised that this video will of
course contain black clover manga
spoilers so please proceed with caution
you have been warned in the previous
chapter we had the magic knight captains
trying their best to fight lucifero but
despite working together and giving it
their all they couldn't really do
anything to hurt him lucifero seemed to
be treating them as little more than
annoying insects who were hovering
around him rather than actual legitimate
threats and he just called all of their
efforts pointless as he beat back one
attack after another i mean the way he
dispatched poor nozelle silva even
became a meme on social media and if a
villain is so strong that he is making a
mockery of even the strongest magic
knight captains then you know that this
man is the real deal now to be fair
sekke still didn't get involved in the
fight he was just shrewdly watching it
all from the sidelines and carefully
plotting how to take lucifero down on
his own i honestly feel bad for lucifero
when seki finally decides to join the
fray but we'll cross that bridge when we
get to it i'm sure that our dark lord
has a good reason for staying out of it
for now despite not being able to do any
real damage to lucifero the magic knight
captains did manage to keep him busy
long enough for asta to sneak up on him
and actually chop a piece of his horns
off of his head this isn't what asta
meant to do he intended to deliver a far
more serious blow with his demon slayer
sword but lucifero managed to dodge
however even the fact that asta was able
to clip off like one little part of his
horn still infuriated lucifero and he
absolutely goes off on asta lucifero
smashes asta into the ground and begins
stomping him to death he just can't
believe that some magicless piece of
trash had the audacity to damage one of
his horns
luckily for asta he is rescued from
certain death by charlotte marielloni
and dorothy let's be real lucifer was
about to kill him in like the next one
or two seconds like this was no joke and
even though he was saved asta is still
severely injured he is no longer in his
devil union mode and both he and chibi
liba look like they're moments away from
death so that's the bad news austin
liebe are down for the count and it
really doesn't look like they'll be
getting up anytime soon like they do not
look good at all the good news is that
the anti-magic attack from asta actually
managed to do some damage no matter how
small to lucifero's body yes even that
minor cut to lucifero's horn represents
a spark of hope for our heroes in an
otherwise extremely bleak situation and
so all of the magic knight captains give
their all to protect asta because they
know that he may end up being their only
hope of defeating lucifero the captains
are literally risking their lives in a
desperate attempt to stop an enraged
lucifero from reaching the unconscious
osta and as they are all fighting and
getting wrecked by lucifero they are
continuing to praise osta someone who
despite being just a magicless peasant
has taught even the strongest royal
blooded mages a very important lesson
never give up even if you are fighting a
much stronger opponent like they all are
now and even if it appears that you
cannot possibly win it is still possible
to win if you keep going if you surpass
your limits and if you fight until the
very end and i have to say as noble as
it is for all of these magic night
captains to sacrifice their bodies to
protect asta and as much as i love the
fact that they are all finally coming to
appreciate asta despite the fact that he
was born as a magicless peasant it is
also absolutely freaking terrifying to
see just how easily lucifero is mopping
the floor with all of these mages that
up to this point were some of the
strongest characters in the entire
series i mean even mero leona and
fugolian going all out with salamander
at their side could not halt lucifero's
advance for even a moment which is
absolutely insane i mean going into this
arc there was so much hype for mere
alone and fugolian going to the same
battlefield together so much hype for
seeing salamander in action and now we
see this oh and may i remind you yet
again that lucifero is only using 50 of
his overall power like those are off the
charts levels of power we are dealing
with right now that emo devil who is
still just casually watching all of this
unfold says that the captains did better
than he expected thanks to real's spell
which allowed them to overcome the
effects of lucifero's gravity magic but
even so it all appears to be over for
them in this moment they've been
absolutely outclassed and incapacitated
by lucifero and so the devil now has a
clear path to osta's lifeless body
lucifero declares that asta is the root
cause of all of his frustrations and he
prepares to literally stomp the life out
of asta once and for all and that is
exactly what he does he kills asta game
over tabata finally memed on all of us
after we were saying that no one dies in
black clover well played tabata well
played okay no of course not right
before lucero kills asta yuno shows up
and uses star magic to teleport asta out
of harm's way with sylph and mimosa by
his side yuno says that now finally asta
is the one who owes him one and as yuno
prepares to face off against lucifero
the chapter comes to an end
whoa let's just step back for a moment
and take in what happened sure okay yuno
is here he has two types of magic now
and he has sylvan mimosa as backup he
certainly did a great job against xenon
and he's way stronger now than he was
when the arc began with all of that said
and with all due respect in a matter of
just a few chapters lucifero has proven
himself to be a complete monster he took
out devil union asta he took out the
entire spade kingdom capital he took out
the magic knight captains and he looks
like he's just getting started there is
no way that yuno even as strong as he is
now has a chance to defeat lucifero the
only potential loophole that i see here
is that star magic could turn out to be
super effective against devils for some
reason like maybe devils are weak
against celestial or divine magic types
like star magic or sun magic that might
give yuno a fighting chance at least for
a little while there's also the
potential that asta nuno will be able to
combine anti-magic and star magic in
order to create black hole magic if they
create black hole magic that could
potentially counter lucifero's gravity
based powers and actually damage him
because of course black holes can
control and affect gravity i made an
entire theory video where i suggested
that osta's anti-magic will eventually
evolve into black hole magic either on
its own or through the combination of
anti-magic and another magic type like
yami's dark magic since black holes are
essentially collapsed stars maybe you
know star magic and asta's anti-magic
working together is what's going to
bring about black hole magic this could
be possible and it would be very cool to
see this if it actually happens and as i
mentioned in that theory video black
hole magic does seem to be the ideal
magic to fight against the strongest
devils because black holes can alter
gravity space and time and those are of
course the three magic attributes used
by the three strongest devils if you
want to check out that video in its
entirety i will link it down in the
description below
but we still have one major problem here
osta is in really really bad shape and
it doesn't look like he will be getting
back up anytime soon if yuno's strategy
for defeating lucifero is combining
asta's anti-magic with his own star
magic to create black hole magic he will
likely have to wait quite a while for
asta to rejoin this fight which means
that he will have to hold lucifero off
on his own and i just don't see that
happening at least not for long with
asta and the magic knight captains
getting bodied by lucifero can yuno
actually make a difference after his big
star magic power up or is he still
nowhere near strong enough to stand
toe-to-toe with lucifero and if yuno
won't be able to defeat lucifer on his
own then what is going to happen next
will that emo devil finally get involved
will yami start using dark magic which
we know is effective against devils will
someone else arrive to back you know up
don't forget to share your thoughts down
in the comments below it feels like
black clover is really setting us up for
an epic finale to this arc and it also
feels like tabata is telling us that we
can't just keep relying on asda and
anti-magic to always save the day on
their own that is just not good enough
anymore and even though anti-magic will
definitely play some role in ultimately
defeating the devils the good guys are
going to require a lot more than just
that in order to defeat someone as
powerful as lucifero do you think that
we might actually see some major deaths
during this battle is tabata about to
meme on all of us who said that no one
dies in black clover by actually killing
off a major character i mean lucifero is
definitely strong enough to kill someone
during this battle but i'm not sure if
black clover as a story is prepared for
something like that i'd love to hear
everyone's opinion on that down in the
comments below if you're looking for a
video to watch next check out my asta
black hole magic theory video link in
the description if you enjoyed this
video and you want to see more in the
future leave a like it helps me out a
lot and of course if you're new to the
channel or maybe you watch our videos
but you still haven't subscribed yet
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all notifications you can also hit me
up on twitter and instagram at
animeopror a big thank you to all of our
anime uproar patrons who make videos
like this one possible special thank you
to alpha sigma and kyle salisbury these
guys are absolute mad lads and disciples
of lord twigo himself and i can't forget
all of our the one tier patrons the ones
who rise above all other clans including
ingrata algertol pate heffa the
red-haired fox hinokamian water the
toasted chi corey mcgowan the spike
spidey life canal tungsten tarkis big
buddhist jeremy cummins and jay whitley
finally thank you also to our pro hero
tier patrons including the one and only
gilgamesh steelers on hell crews very
gucci alicia octor bonnie parks joy and
garcia fat boy games kaido might be a
duck jessica rabbit jeremy phillips and
alivania if you guys enjoy our videos
and you feel that they provide value to
you consider supporting us on patreon
even a single dollar will give you
access to our patreon exclusive discord
and you will be directly supporting this
channel in a very real way as always
thank you guys so much for watching and
until next time see us peace cowboys
[Music]